Juston revealing he spent much of last
year suffering from a debilitating
disease as humans we go through so many
ups and downs sometimes we want to give
up for the past four months we've seen
Bieber leaving the doctor's office over
and over always with an IV in his arm
well now we know the reason Justin has
Lyme disease I believe that I'm right
where I'm supposed to be and God has me
right where he wants me Bieber dropped
the news today on Instagram and in his
upcoming docu-series seasons so now we
know those IVs apparently weren't
vitamin drips they may have been filled
with medicine to treat the disease
Justin says he also had mono which is
what caused those pretty bad breakout we
all different stories I'm just excited
to share mine so how'd Bieber get Lyme
disease well it comes from a tick bite
and check this out
ironically back in October of 2018 a
public health department used Justin as
their poster boy on how to protect
yourself from ticks be like Justin
Bieber tuck your pants into your socks
[Music]